Hello, and welcome back to the complete guide
to Kubescape.
In this second video, we'll be taking a
look at how to use Kubescape
from your own machine via the Kubescape CLI.
We'll then be progressing to using Kubescape in
CI environments like GitHub Actions,
allowing us to scan for misconfigurations
right from the pull request.
Before we get started, thank you again to
Armo for sponsoring this series on the complete
guide to Kubescape.
Let's have some fun.
Alright.
Let's take a high level look at the
Kubescape CLI.
First, we can run kubescapescandot.
Now before I run this, I'll just show
you that in this directory, we have the
Google microservice
demo and the Weaveworks Sockshop demo.
So there's a lot of manifests
and not only that, there's a mixed variety
of types of manifests.
In some of these directories, we have a
helm chart, and some we have customized, and
some we have straight up Kubernetes YAML.
So let's run Kubescape scan dot. This will
scan recursively
through all of these manifests and types of
manifests to give us a report on this
configuration.
Nice.
So from here, we can see that we
have
failed controls
out of 70,
but none are critical.
So silver lining.
As far as the high severity goes, we
can see that
we are delivering application credentials and configuration files.
We are not applying security context to pods
and containers.
We have some pods and containers with
elevated privileges,
host network access, host path mounts,
the ability to list Kubernetes secrets, so on.
We can see here that a hundred and
nine
of our resources
are not applying the correct community context to
pods and containers.
If we scroll down a bit more, we'll
see that we have a hundred and nine
images allowed from any registry
and a hundred nine containers or pods without
a seccomp profile.
In fairness,
some of these are quite standard. Seccomp is
not something that I see as widely adopted.
But now that we have a target, a
number to reduce,
let's start applying those seccomp profiles even if
you're just using the new defaults in Kubernetes
one twenty three. Let's run a couple more
scans before we dive into these in a
little bit more detail.
When we ran the first scan, we didn't
specify any framework, so it was analyzing against
all of them.
However, we can say we want to scan,
get the NSA framework
in this directory.
So depending on what your security posture is
and which frameworks you choose internally to adopt,
this will narrow the scope of the controls
being used against your scan. It might make
it a little bit easier to start getting
those numbers down and improving your security posture.
Now if we take a look at the
extra code of this command, we'll see it's
zero.
It may be that you actually want to
fill this because there's a severity threshold that
goes against your service levels. Perhaps you don't
want to allow anything with a critical violation
to pass your CI process.
For this, we can add severity
threshold,
and we'll say that we want to fail
on anything that's critical.
If we echo the response here, we get
a zero.
Now let's run that again
with hi.
And you'll see that we have a fatal
warning at the end of the command telling
us that our threshold was met.
And if we do an echo on the
result code, we have a one.
So this is a nice way to build
a short feedback loop to know if various
frameworks or controls are in violation of what
you're trying to adopt with your security posture.
Speaking of controls,
we can actually run Kubescape to scan for
individual controls too.
Perhaps we want to make sure that host
paths are not used in any of our
Kubernetes manifest.
So how do we get the ID of
that control?
Well, we can run Kubescape
list
control,
which will list all the controls available for
us to filter on.
We can then grep
for host path.
Now that we have the name, we can
run Kubescape
scan for a single control.
I'm going to use host path mount, which
is just the name of the control that
we want to scan for,
and then pass in our path.
And here we'll see we have two failed
resources
that are using a control we don't want
them to use.
And as it says at the bottom of
this output,
simply a dash v
to get more information on the resources themselves.
Now we can see that our Prometheus exporter
and Fluent d daemon
are the resources in violation of this control.
However,
we know that Prometheus and Fluentd do need
slightly more elevated access to the host, including
host path nodes.
It's the nature of what they do, So
you can log in to Kubescape SaaS like
we did in the first video,
add the exceptions,
and we're good. These violations will no longer
be present on the CLI.
Let's take a look at two more features
of the Kubescape CLI.
Let's go into the Google demo directory.
And you'll see here,
we have a tree
that is a customized directory.
This is a set of Kubernetes manifest where
we have a customization dot YAML.
If you're familiar with customize,
this will allow us to take a safe
set of resources
and apply some overlays,
which means that when we're scanning these,
we can't just scan
what is inside the base directory,
the vanilla manifest.
We have to account for the fact that
the customizations may change or reshape those manifests.
And Kubescape supports us at the box.
If we run
if we run
Kubescapescandot,
we'll see on the info login line that
the scanner has started,
and then we have this line here.
Customizations are actually detected,
scanning the rendered
objects.
This is important. It's important for Kubescape to
understand that we don't just use vanilla manifest
because those won't be what hit our clusters
directly.
And to confirm this works,
we can modify the customization file.
We can see that we have some common
labels,
updates app,
hello world,
and app,
hello world.
Now when we save this and scan again,
Our label usage for resources went from 25
to 13.
Awesome.
Now,
Kubescape doesn't just handle customize and customizations,
but also
help charts.
Here we have a chart on YAML and
a templates directory
like so.
Now, of course,
templates within a Helm chart could be straight
up Kubernetes manifest YAML,
but more often than not,
they are littered and composed of many, many
Go template string.
But Kubescape doesn't mind.
If we do a Kubescape scan,
then we'll see that we have the same
label,
Kubernetes common label,
failed resources. Only this time, the number is
12.
So let's change the helm value style.
And here, I'm going to add labels,
k that,
hello world,
and app.
Hello
world.
And run Kubescape scan
one more time.
We'll see that our label usage went from
to seven.
Now that is because I only patched a
few of those deployment. Yaml to actually use
the new top level labels value in the
values file. However, it's enough to confirm that
Kubescape is rendering our helm chart before
applying the controls,
and the same for customize.
And that's pretty cool.
So let's move on to the second part
of today's demo.
How do we integrate Kubescape into our CI
process?
It's all very well and good that I
can install
Kubescape locally on my machine, scan my resources,
but it's 2022,
almost 2023.
We need to automate this.
So we need to bake this in to
our CI process
so we get alerts for the controls that
we care about the most, whether that be
all the criticals or a certain framework or
one or two controls that you never want
to hack your production cluster, that is up
to you. So let's see how it's done.
So here I am
in the GitHub repository for the clustered automation.
Why? Well, because in here,
we have a deployment manifest.
A config map, a service on a stateful
set for Postgres,
and a service for the clustered application.
These manifests have not been written with security
in mind, given that they're used primarily for
a show in breaking Kubernetes clusters.
However,
why don't we set this repository up to
take advantage
of Kubescape in a CI environment?
Now, until recently,
you would have to orchestrate and manage getting
the Kubescape CLI yourself,
running it against your code, and uploading the
artifact
on your GitHub release.
But that's all changed
from the first week in December.
There's now a GitHub action
that automates this entire process for you.
So the first thing we're going to do
is create a new workflow.
We'll call this security
dot YAML.
We can give this a name and say
security scanning
or clustered
manifests.
We want to run this on push events
and we'll do all of them and pull
request.
Next, we define a job
and we'll just call this Kubescape and we're
going to say that it runs on
Ubuntu latest.
Now we have a few steps as part
of this. One, as with all GitHub actions,
we need to do checkout.
Well, maybe we're going to use checkout b
three.
Now,
we can use
the Kubescape
GitHub
action
on the latest version.
Now at the moment, we don't want this
to fail
if there is an error, so we're gonna
set this to true.
Now we can configure the action
using the with keyword.
Now we can configure the format
using the format key.
How do we work out which formats are
supported?
It's the same formats provided
in the Kubescape scan
help output.
You'll see here we can use pretty printer,
JSON, GA unit, Prometheus, PDF, HTML,
or SADIF.
Let's grab
pretty printer.
Next, we can specify the path that we
wish to scan.
For me, that's going to be workload
opt Kubernetes.
Workload opt Kubernetes.
And that should be enough to get this
started.
So let's commit and push.
Alright.
Now we can pop over
to the run itself,
And we'll give that just a moment.
I'm done.
Now,
that completed relatively fast because it's not really
scanning much.
And you'll see when we expand it, there's
also very little output that is available to
us.
And this is because when you specify the
output format, Kubescape is going to write that
format to a file. In our case, a
results dot out file.
We can come back to our action and
add another step.
So let's add a step
so that we can see the output.
Here, we can do cat
result
dot out.
And we'll be nice and we'll give this
a name,
like so.
We add a commit message,
and we push.
Now we can pop over
to to our action
where our next action has no running,
hopefully.
Alright. We can open the results,
and now
the output from our scan is visible from
all our action runners.
Because this is probably not the best way
to get started.
Let's come back and modify the format
to be JUnit.
And now we're going to use an action
for publishing g unit reports.
And we can tell it to run
with the report paths
of anything dot XML.
And now we can push this,
and we'll see a new XML report added
to our repository.
Let's go back to our actions.
Now we can see the JUnit report parser.
It's created a lovely report
from all the controls.
And what's even nicer about this
is if we come back to the summary
of this job
and scroll to the bottom,
we'll see the test report here where we
ran 406
tests, 40 passed, a whole bunch were skipped,
and we have 47
failing.
So increasing
the ability to understand, visualize
the controls that are failing with our manifest.
Let's take a look at one more improvement.
Now we're going to change from JUnit
to SARIF.
What is SARIF?
Well,
it is the static analysis
results interchange
format.
Easy.
It is a common format used,
especially by CodeQL from GitHub,
for understanding the results of static static analysis
scanning
of code and other artifacts.
So now we need to change the final
step
and remove the g unit
uploading.
So now that we've removed the g unit
test, the g unit step,
let's pop down.
Thank you, Copilot.
And add the GitHub official CodeQL action for
uploading a SARIF artifact.
You'll see here that it's set to SARIF
file would be kubescape results dot SARIF.
We can add
the output file
to the kubescape step
and just ensure
that the names match.
We can save this,
write a nice commit message
and push.
And now when we go back to GitHub
to our most recent run of GitHub actions
runner,
hopefully give it just a few seconds to
complete,
it will upload the SARIF file to GitHub
code scanning.
Finally.
Now that took nearly two and a half
minutes. However, it's important to note the Kubescape
scan was very quick. The upload to code
scanning is very quick. However, you may find
there's a delay waiting for CodeQL
to analyze the report.
But now that that's finished, we can go
to the security tab on our repository.
From here, you'll see that code scanning alerts
have been enabled.
And when we click on a few of
the alerts,
you'll see something interesting.
Our workflow security scanning for clustered manifest,
which ran one minute ago,
has opened
code scanning issues for me to work on,
integrating
the entire Kubescape process
into your GitHub workflow.
From here, we can click on one of
them.
It will show us the manifest where the
control was violated.
It gives us a nice error message
and tells you how to remediate the problem.
From here,
you can choose to dismiss the alert as
won't fix false positive or it's just a
test,
or you could create an issue
for someone on your team or in open
source land to come and provide a fix.
So that is Kubescape integrated
in the CI process with GitHub actions.
That's pretty sweet.
So there you have it. Kubescape on the
CLI,
integrated into CI,
and even one step further, integrated directly
into your GitHub development workflow.
Go check it out. Have some fun.
If you have any questions or any problems,
leave a comment in the comment section below
or reach out via Twitter. I can't wait
to speak to you. Have a great day.